wir haben in diesem land wir haben es
eben auch schon mal bei ihrem thema wir
haben in diesem land eine spaltung
zwischen arm und reich die diskutieren
wir schon seit vielen jahren und man
kann aber feststellen dass sie stärker
geworden ist in den letzten jahren und
durch die pandemie jetzt auch noch mal
stärker geworden ist also es gab viele
leute die den
beschäftigungsverhältnissen waren wo sie
dann auf kurzarbeitergeld gegangen sind
bis zu zwei jahren und eben sehr viel
weniger einkommen hatten die ausgaben
aber nicht signifikant runtergegangen
sind also die differenz von einkommen
und vermögen steigt und ich bin der
auffassung oder nicht nur ich das
gefährdet unsere demokratie auf der
strecke weil wir eben auch feststellen
können dass es der aktuelle bezugspunkt
die wahl in nordrhein-westfalen letztes
wochenende wir haben nur eine
wahlbeteiligung von 55 prozent gehabt
und davon haben einkommensschwache nur
mit 38 prozent
gewählt und in orten wie köln chorweiler
beispielsweise waren sogar nur 21,9
prozent die wählen gegangen sind will
heißen die gut ausgebildete und
gebildete mittelschicht geht wählen und
vertritt ihre interessen und diejenigen
die sich abgehängt fühlen die gehen auch
erst gar nicht mehr wählen und das wird
immer schlimmer die wahlbeteiligung
sinkt kontinuierlich und mein
schlüsselerlebnis sag ich ganz ehrlich
war 2010 in hamburg als der schwarz
grüne senat unter ole von beust damals
ein konzept auf den tisch gelegt hat
dass die schülerinnen und schüler bis
zur sechsten klasse gemeinsam in die
schule gehen sollen weil man weiß dass
leute aus also dass kinder aus familien
wo man sich nicht so sehr um sie kümmert
wie in anderen familien dann besser
gefördert werden
und dann haben eltern aus eben besagter
mittelschicht angefangene
volksinitiative dagegen zu machen es gab
eine volksabstimmung und die eltern der
kinder die eigentlich hätten dafür
stimmen müssen dass das so wird wie der
senat will händler wir haben sich nicht
beteiligt an der abstimmung und dann
haben die anderen gewonnen also nach der
vierten klasse geht man in hamburg
weiter aus gymnasium und die kinder
werden eben nicht in dem maße gefördert
wie sie gefördert werden könnten und so
kann man das jetzt eben auch auf die
ganz auf das system demokratie runter
dekliniert also wir müssen da einfach
was machen wenn wir unser system erhält
wollen was ja auch an vielen anderen
stellen bedroht ist du hast eben china
genannt hast in ukraine genannte
cyberwar und ähnliches mehr also die
ganzen sozialen medien was alles damit
rein spielt ist alles nur ein
riesenthema aber was führt dann am ende
so weit das ist doch nicht der cyberwar
bei den menschen warum sie nicht zur
wahl gehen das
war am ende dann irgendwie auch ihre
parteikollegin mit dem sohn mit dem
helikopter nach suhl fliegt da haben die
beuten leute halte einfach keinen bock
mehr dann drauf und sagen sich die da
oben das ist ja immer stärker geworden
das erlebe ich doch auch selbst bei mir
in der heimat in thüringen die leute
haben einfach dann keine lust mehr sich
damit zu beschäftigen weil sie sich halt
verarscht vorkommen und nicht meinen die
letzte wahl sollte ja schon irgendwie so
ein neuer neustart werden ich glaube die
leute waren noch recht ready dafür und
der einzige der grat punkte deshalb
robert habeck war das ordentlich erklärt
und man seine politik muss man nun mal
erklären ja das hat frau merkel immer zu
wenig gemacht herr habe macht zeit gut
werden gerade die großen debatten aber
er hat halten er ist eben minütigen
video erklärt und erklärt warum
warum warum warum diese spaltung da ist
oder warum die menschen eben sich dann
einfach also warum auch diese soziale
spaltung dann halt da und dann endet das
haben sie ja auch gesagt warum die leute
nicht mehr zur wahl gehen aber die jetzt
wenn wir jetzt zum beispiel gerade köln
oder auch köln chorweiler nicht wundert
ehrlich gesagt nicht dass in solchen
stadtteilen niemand zur wahl geht weil
dort ein klientel wohnt das quasi fast
fast zu 100% irgendwie von staatlicher
alimentierung lebt denen es völlig egal
wer regiert weil es für ihr persönliches
leben über auch finanziell überhaupt gar
keinen grund mich
sagen aber das interesse sozusagen in
irgendeiner form zu sagen ich will eine
andere politische ordnung ich will diese
würde jene forderung das macht dort für
viele menschen überhaupt keinen
unterschied wer regiert so und da ist
das interesse nicht da ich glaube
allerdings dass gerade endlich sagen es
ist ja nicht nur sozusagen in
bildungsfernen schichten wird nicht
gewählt sondern zunehmend auch im
bürgerlichen lager zunehmend eigentlich
ja auch leute wo man sagt die waren
früher wählen das macht mir viel mehr
sorgen weil diese leute offensichtlich
irgendwie auch kein unterschied mehr
sehen höher was mich in der 7
aus dem was manche zu groß sagt ist
oftmals ja wir brauchen mehr staatliche
förderung wir brauchen mehr hier für die
seminar für jene minderheit oder so
wie kommen wir da raus aus dieser und
der sieger aus dieser lage und und ich
und was wir tun ist auch die spd mit dem
arbeits und sozialministerium milliarden
und milliarden jedes jahr an
transferleistung aus dem bundesrat zu
nehmen und sie schön zu verteilen und
wundern sich warum der die zumindest
zuweisung für soziale kompetenz in
nordrhein westfalen um elf prozent
ausweisen von infratest dimap weiß ich
ob das stimmt aber zumindest haben die
so gemeldet gefallen ist obwohl diese
ganz milliarden verteilt worden sind in
den letzten jahren muss man sich doch
die frage stellt warum ist das so und
gibt es nicht bessere wege als immer nur
transfer hier transfer tat und das als
sozialer gerechtigkeit zu verkaufen
etwas was offenbar bei den bürgerinnen
und bürgern zumindest in nordrhein
westfalen nicht angekommen ist und da
bin ich wirklich bei der
chancengerechtigkeit die wir uns immer
auf die fahne schreiben aber wie sieht
es denn aus mit ganztagsschulen über die
wir den ganzen tag reden wie sieht es
denn wirklich aus mit der betreuung wir
waren bei denen beim tollen event da war
frau märz immerhin cdu geführtes
bundesland damals noch in nordrhein
westfalen in düsseldorf hat gesagt wenn
ich mir das so angucke hat sich hier
überhaupt nichts verändert in den
letzten 30 jahren das sagte sie als nrw
cdu geführt wird was die betreuung von
jugendlichen oder von kindern in der
schule angeht oder die möglichkeit von
frauen dann auch tat sich am nachmittag
arbeiten zu können mit betreuten kindern
da nichts verbessert die ausstattung von
schulen der rede sagt kroner
lehrermangel ist es denn mit dem jungen
handlung ist mit den ausstellern
arbeiterjugend arbeiter jugendclubs
ipads in den schulen passiert da was
oder passiert da nichts zum teil steht
der bund milliarden zur verfügung das
grundgesetz wird geändert aber trotzdem
versiegt das irgendwo in den ländern und
da muss man doch endlich mal ran und
dann kann man chancengerechtigkeit über
spracherwerb über die möglichkeit
wirklich alle zu fordern meinetwegen
auch über die sechs jahren daneben um
setzt aber warum sind denn die die leute
dann dagegen auch in hamburg bei
natürlich auch eine mittelschicht angst
hat und dass ihre kinder abgehängt
werden wenn sie noch vier jahre zwei
jahre mehr mit denen zusammen sind die
sie nicht als die nicht gefördert werden
und von denen sie meinen sie ziehen den
unterricht runter gerecht ist das nicht
aber so ist die realität und da hilft
wirklich nur mehr investieren man kann
sich nicht mehr hören aber es wird nicht
mitgemacht laufen also ich möchte wird
gerappt erzählen eine freundin von mir
ist in einem problemviertel in köln
grundschullehrerin und die er sagte mir
gerade erst sonntag erzählte mir dass
sie ich kann nicht mehr sagt sie ich
kann langsam einfach nicht mehr sagte
seit 2015 haben wir die halbe klasse
voll haben sagte ich habe kinder
migrantenanteil von bestimmt 60 80
prozent an der schule sagt sie das ist
schon in normalen jüngste generation ja
ja genauso anstrengend das ist schon
anstrengend genug sagt sie dann haben
wir die flüchtlingskinder bekommen wir
tun und machen das sie werden nicht mehr
personal bekommen so das ist jetzt haben
wir das halbwegs irgendwie in den griff
bekommen dann kam corona soja dann haben
wir jetzt corona irgendwie bewältigt
jetzt haben wir kaum konzern bekommen
die schulen wieder offen jetzt haben wir
die ukrainischen flüchtlingskinder da
diese schulen werden aber nicht mehr
ausgestattet sie bekommen nicht mehr
personal sie sind sie sind im endeffekt
auch die lehrer sind am ende ihrer
kräfte und dann ist es ganz egal ob
diese kinder vier jahre oder sechs jahre
in dieser grundschule sind wenn wir
nicht insgesamt mehr investieren in die
schule und wenn das nicht wichtiger wird
insgesamt ja dass man sagt wie findet
das überhaupt stattfindet schule
überhaupt statt ja und wie können wir
kinder fördern
oder das
geld ist aber sie sagen werden nicht
abgehoben teilweise wird von den ländern
nicht abgerufen wenigstens was diese
ipad geschichten anbelangte und am auf
der anderen seite ist es auch so dass es
schon sehr vieles besser geworden ist
also jetzt ist haben sie jetzt irgendwie
alles negative aufgezählt was man
aufzählen kann aber es gibt aber
natürlich auch viele gibt aber auch
viele gegenbeispiele die sie benennen
können wo sie sagen können das ist eine
tolle schule da sind genug lehrer da die
kümmern sich und da sind engagierte
lehrer es hängt oft halt auch an den
schulleiter muss man sich helga sind
auch alle engagiert aber ich will nur
sagen die sind am ende ihrer kräfte
das glaube ich aber auch sofort aber
sind ganz ganz viele nach dem ende der
pandemie am ende ihrer kräfte auch die
ganzen eltern die die kinder zu hause
betreuen mussten so ist es ja nun mal
nicht
und nutzt eben die schultern der
ehrenämtler der der leute die jetzt
wirklich helfen das haben wir am
berliner hauptbahnhof bei der aufnahme
von den ukrainern und gesehen gar nicht
nur der stadt reagiert gar nicht schnell
genug und überhaupt nicht dass sich
andere staaten können das auch allein
wenn man geht nicht wir können solche
mengen von menschen die von heute auf
morgen kommen nicht durch staatliche
institutionen
auffangen können weil da müssen sie in
einer art und weise vorsorge wirtschaft
treiben und leute bereit halten ständig
auf die gefahr hin dass man irgendwie
alle paar jahre so was passiert das
macht ihr überhaupt gar keinen sinn also
ist mit 16 thüring war hatte ich eben
oder mit 14 daten wir eben ich war einem
offenen kanal den gab resta gab es
jugendprogramme es gab es gab
jugendhelfer dies gab jugendclubs und so
weiter also das angebot ist so
zurückgefahren worden und als kobe dann
kam und auch noch sportangebote und
sportvereine sich nicht mehr getroffen
haben das hat dann das übelste getan und
also ich kenne heute selbst
bekanntenkreis wo die enkel dann
magersucht haben und und da die
hilfsangebote begrenzt denn das zählt
jetzt wieder zu sehr auf krone ansonsten
die spaltung aber dieser lehrermangel
und dieses dieses diese bildung so zu
vernachlässigen ich glaube da wurde
schon recht viel falsch gemacht ja aber
vielleicht die antwort zum frage anreiz
irgendwie aus der armut weil wir sind ja
nicht in frage ist ja in frage ist wie
kommen wir da raus und was mir immer ein
bisschen fehlt wie er sie bei mir
stellen sich ja immer die nackenhaare
aufwendig umverteilung höre ja weil ich
immer sage irgendjemand muss das ja
verdienen was umverteilt wird und ich
arbeite ja auch den ganzen tag um meine
kinder zu ernähren und auch viele im
niedriglohnsektor stehen morgens auf und
machen ihre arbeit und mir fehlt immer
ein bisschen der anreiz ich möchte nicht
umverteilen ich finde das auch
entwürdigend langfristig
mindestlohn verteilen sie ein gewisser
weise auch um und es ist richtig dass
der mindestlohn eingeführt wurde und ist
es auch richtig dass der mindestlohn
erhöht wurde aber gleichzeitig ist es
trotzdem so dass dass wir zu viel wir
haben einen wachsenden anteil von
menschen die von transferleistungen
leben das sind die bis in die rente
hinein nicht von ihrem eigenen
erwirtschafteten geld erleben können